new figures show a shocking rise in
deaths linked to a street drug which
rots the skin of those who use it
xylacine often referred to as tranq or
the zombie drug has spread across
America at such alarming speed that the
White House has now released a new
six-point action plan to tackle the
crisis the drug and animal tranquilizer
is increasingly mixed or cut by drug
dealers into supplies of fentanyl which
itself is already killing over a hundred
thousand Americans every year according
to the most recent data from 20 U.S
states and the District of Columbia the
monthly percentage of fentanyl
Associated deaths where xylazine was
detected has increased by 276 percent
from 2.9 percent to 10.9 percent